russie si elle a insisté très fortement
sur cet élargissement de l'otan qui est
un point qui revient dans le débat et
dans le discours russe depuis depuis
quasiment toujours depuis les
élargissements depuis 97 ce n'était pas
le seul il ya aussi d'arriver à avoir un
traité de sécurité et un peu plus de
demain du côté russe évidemment cette
demande sur les déploiements militaires
et aussi finalement d'arriver à avoir
une neutralisation de l'ukraine qui
pourrait passer par l'implémentation
complète des accords de minsk 2 qui pour
l'instant ne le sont pas donc ces
accords qui ont été signés dans les
foyers le 2015 et qui ne sont toujours
toujours pas appliquée puisqu'il était
considéré comme inapplicable notamment
par du crem l'apport du délit d'injure
strates de négociations la porte du
dialogue en tout cas elle reste ouverte
justement emmanuel macron le président
français et vladimir poutine doivent
discuter demain vendredi est ce que ça
peut faire avancer les choses la france
est-elle perçu par moscou comme un
interlocuteur de poids dans ce dossier
lors la france a l'avantagé d'avoir fait
partie du format normandie avec
l'allemagne qui a été un des acteurs ou
du moins qui a tenté d'être un des
acteurs de la résolution de ce conflit
qui est malheureusement toujours en
cours
comme on le voit mais on a bien vu que
dans les débats moscou a voulu traiter
directement avec washington et au final
ne s'est pas demandé et n'a pas demandé
à ce que l'union européenne ou même la
france donne le soin à la table des
négociations sont arrivés qu'en deuxième
position avec un petit peu une posture
de junior partner à l'heure actuelle par
ailleurs la russie est en règle générale
très au fait des agendas politiques des
états avec lesquels elle traite et je
pense qu'il ne lui aura pas échappé que
nous allons rentrer dans une période de
campagne présidentielle qui n'est pas en
règle générale le moment où on peut
faire le plus de choix stratégiques
forts et pourquoi avoir mis de les
européens de côté depuis le début
alors la russie et dans un alors on
avait déjà eu un petit peu ça sur la
lors du premier déploiement militaire du
printemps dernier ou la russie expliqué
que non elle voulait discuter d'égal à
égal que les états d'europe avec l'union
européenne n'était pas à ce niveau de
négociation et qu'il voulait traiter
directement avec washington et avec le
président biden en estimant et en
envoyant le message aussi très clair que
finalement le temps dépend des
principalement des états unis donc c'est
un petit peu positionner dans un rapport
de force et dire voilà nous ne discutons
que avec et bien les principaux
intervenants et les plus importants donc
on est vraiment dans ce positionnement
là c'est un petit peu d'expliquer que ce
n'est pas l'autre junior partner on est
deux superpuissances à super puissance
et c'est la position annoncée
je me demande si cela fait des mois que
la russie masse des troupes à la
frontière avec l'ukraine vous l'avez
évoqué ça a commencé au printemps
dernier qu'est ce qui a provoqué cette
crise et l'arrivée de joe biden au
pouvoir justement aux états unis
vladimir poutine a voulu montrer les
muscles
alors il y a eu un ensemble de
circonstances et d'agendas qui
permettait de pouvoir organiser donc si
on parle du printemps dernier une sorte
de stress tests pour les états unis donc
l'élection du président bayonne qui
avait représenté un espoir pour
notamment l'ukraine après la mandature
trump qui avait eu le président bailon
rappelez-vous des mots extrêmement durs
pour la russie au début de sa mandature
notamment concernant les attaques cyber
donc il y avait eu il y avait déjà une
première passe d'armes donc il y avait
une façon de tester un petit peu et de
repositionner déjà à l'époque
l'union européenne alors disant écoutez
voilà nous traitons avec les états unis
mais chez vous vous n'êtes pas loin
géographiquement si jamais la situation
dégénère vous êtes vous êtes aux
premières loges donc on avait déjà un
petit peu ce principe là et là on a sept
principes qui est renforcée et pourquoi
parce qu'on a une situation générique de
crise et de dissensions au niveau de
l'union européenne qui est
particulièrement propice quand vous
voulez utiliser les dissensions et avoir
un rapport de force nous avons eu
différentes différentes divisions nord
stream en a été une nous avons dû faire
face la pologne particulièrement à
l'afflux des migrants
organisé depuis la biélorussie
nous avons eu les problèmes avec la
crise énergétique est la montée des
tarifs donc tous ces éléments là qui ont
été autant de points de perturbations
qui sont utilisables quelque part par la
russie notamment pour marquer des points
et obtenir et bien c'est qu'elle veut
dans un cadre de négociations alors
justement moi justement les gêner si la
division les négociations elles vont se
poursuivre aussi dans deux semaines à
berlin au format normandie qu'est ce
qu'on peut en attendre
alors monsieur coup les balles avait dit
très clairement la bonne nouvelle c'est
que le fête ses quinze jours donne
quinze jours de répit et de descendre de
tension et on va voir ce qui se passera
la question est jusqu'où la russie veut
aller et qu'ils allaient à son
quel est le prix minimum de sa
négociation et jusqu'au est ce que nous
on ira ils vont très clairement
continuer à remettre la pression ce
qu'il demande en massant des troupes aux
frontières de l'ukraine en 2022 c'est un
retour dans le passé en 97 au niveau 2
au niveau de l'otan c'est-à-dire un
repli de l'otan de l'étranger proche de
la russie
ils savent que ils n'auront pas gain de
cause sur ce qu'ils demandent maintenant
ils peuvent espérer d'avoir des
renégociations notamment sur les traités
de sécurité et de voir ce qui ce que
cela pourra donner il y a aussi un autre
point c'est que au delà de l'otan parce
que là on parle beaucoup de l'otan et
des états unis mais au milieu il ya tout
de même l'ukraine et les ukrainiens pays
qui est en souffrance et qui serait au
premier en ligne au cas où il y aura un
déclenchement cinétique et vous avez de
la part de la russie un attachement très
fort émotionnel et qui peut parfois
aller jusqu'à de l'irrationnel à
l'ukraine il y a eu un article signé de
la main de vladimir poutine l'été de cet
été alors à l'été 2000 21 qu'il qui est
signalé très clairement il ya aussi
cette approche-là merci beaucoup
christine dubois 1 clément d'avoir été
notre invité ce soir sur france 24 pour
revenir sur ce dossier ukrainien